so uh now introduce Ryan he's an
engineer at stripe and he'll be talking
on scikit-learn for or just probably
just like general okay so general were
detecting fraud um using machine
learning stripe so over to Brian yes it
thanks everybody for your time I'm kind
of hard to follow up that previous talk
but I guess if like you really want to
be philosophical I we're kind of trying
to tell the difference between Eric and
Derek so like a lot of fraud turns out
to come from pots um yeah so the tell my
talk is if it weighs the same a duck the
same as a duck detecting for all the
Python machine learning so I figured I
had to throw in some money Python if
you've ever watched that scene if not
you should definitely should all right
so anyway they the outline of this talk
I'll first talk about like why do we use
machine learning in the first place for
stopping fraud talk about kind of what
her pipeline looks like and then talk
through some i guess like war stories
about like what happened when we tried
to like update various models and like
challenges that we face and I think
they'll be pretty fun um so for those of
you that don't know what stripe is we
provide an API for collecting payments
so if you if you have like a web app or
like a mobile app you would send a
request to our API and be like charge
this credit card this amount and so it's
it's basically as simple as like does it
come from the python bindings like
striped charge that created so naturally
as like a payment service one of our big
problems that we face is people trying
to defraud either us directly or our
users who are merchants trying to sell
stuff online this is a banner from like
a carding website which is where people
go to buy stolen credit cards and I
guess they have like spent a lot of time
on advertising because it's like Uncle
Sam I want you to swipe
basically the problem that we face is
people go to one of these websites by a
bunch of stolen credit cards and then so
like one type of fraud is they'll make a
fake stripe account and charge all the
stolen credit cards then when we send
them transfer them the money they
disappear and because they're stolen
credit cards eventually all these
charges will get disputed and we'll be
like okay we can't get that money back
favorite type is like people buy from
our users and like this is extremely
frustrating and annoying for people
because basically 22 months later after
you've collected charge you find out is
fraudulent the bank were like a credit
card network ask for their money back
and then you've you've lost money and
you have to pay like fines or like fees
for like processing disputes and you've
also lost the value of your good so it's
super annoying and it's something we
really try stop the other weird kind is
people trying to test like stolen credit
card couldn't credentials so these are
like bots that like send thousands of
charges like in a minute like and
they're just trying to figure out like
do these credentials work or sometimes
they have a list of stolen cards and
they'll be like okay can't charge five
dollars with this card yeah can I charge
ten dollars yeah I can i charge 50 i'm
just trying to figure out like how much
money can you get out of card um so yeah
so that's kind of the problem we're
trying to solve how do we go about it
well the first thing we realize is that
it's easier to detect witches than fraud
this is a scene from the my Python skit
anyway so the first region of our fraud
system was what involved a lot of manual
rules and aggressive blacklisting so
kind of like right when strike was
launched like discovered a bunch of like
goofy looking like strange-looking
transactions and it's like okay we
probably need to build in some like some
like some some system for for stopping
fraud and that work for quite a while
until like our volumes start to like
really great
financially and you can imagine like
this the issues that we faced in scaling
scaling a bunch of manual rules mostly
it's very hard to control precision like
the precision recall trade-off like you
could always have no fraud right if you
just block every transaction or you
could just like have really specific
rules for like every single edge case
that you could detect the other problem
is like complexity grows really quickly
and I think thats related to the other
thing I said about like the other point
on this slide about like it doesn't
really generalize very well yeah it like
as good as you think you can be like
creating manual rules a lot of time they
really are picking out edge cases but
the upshot is we actually got a lot of
really important tools from building
like this initial fraud system so like I
don't have a screenshot I wish I could
but it's it's an internal tool that we
have that allows you to do like I'm
graph search over charges so for example
you could be like oh this charge looks
sketchy let me show me all related
charges like from the same email address
or something and then you can kind of
like start to pick out patterns and like
okay think about okay what features
would capture these patterns so the
current system is based on machine
learning we have tree based models like
random forests the estimate like
probably of frog given teachers I'm just
given two characteristics of every
charge and that output scores that we
then use used to like we analyze like
okay what's the precision recall with
associate with any given score then
action based on scores and when we train
the models there is this composite
outcome that we use it's composed of
disputes manual tags that like people
like you ever go and look at the charge
and say okay this is probably fraud and
we also get information from card
networks and the reason that we don't
really have a single ground truth is
because like if you think about how
disputes work not every charge that's
fraudulent is going to get disputed in
fact a lot of them are gonna get
declined because
Thanks and like credit card networks are
also running their own fraud algorithms
but you do really want to use that
information when you're training a model
and now the actual python that we use is
uh there's you know we have a is a great
ecosystem around like model training and
model evaluation for for Python and we
use a lot of that we also use it to glue
together a bunch of different tasks for
for creating features and interacting
with the rest of our databases so here's
kind of a picture of like what this
pipeline looks like I don't know where
we usually start I guess probably like
like it'll be somebody from support say
or from risk will be like okay here like
we have users complaining about like
this type of problem like a bunch of
charges coming from the same email and
like why aren't we stopping those those
types of fraudulent charges and then
we'll go through this whole cycle of
okay creating features and then training
models and then evaluating the models
and then throwing them into staging
before we actually deploy them to
production and I guess like the main
thing my main point here is just that
like these are all equally sized in this
like flowchart graphy thing but like
actually we spend most of our time
working on like model evaluation and
feature engineering and like the machine
learning II like stuff of that I think
people typically think of like oh like
have you tried neural networks like that
actually we don't really spend a whole
lot of time on I think that there was a
guy who gave a talk like before this
keynote who's saying like a machine
learning is like a lot of effective date
of management and I think that's
definitely been our experience as well
um
yeah so what does it take to update a
model I'll kind of just like walk
through like some stories about
involving like the first three parts of
this this cycle of like feature
engineering etc so you have future
engineering basically turns out to be
like a bunch of counting stuff which
sounds simple but it actually gets kind
of hard when you have like hundreds of
millions of data points actually even
without hundreds of millions of data
points counting stuff can be kind of
hard and what the reason i call it
accounting stuff is because um actually
the most useful features that we use
turned out to involve counting stuff
like so we have like static features of
like things that come from from from
charges like okay where what country was
discharged made and like does it match
all the other like details that might
might be on this charge but like these
are kind of things that you like
calculate once like what's the
probability of fraud if like this charge
came from the philippines and they're
like really marginal right like that
like okay this charge came from the
philippines like that's not enough for
you to say okay definitely or definitely
is are definitely not fraud right the
stuff that turns out to be really useful
is is this the types of stuff that
utilizes like the entire stripe network
and so then you count things like okay
how many times have I seen charges come
from the same email in the last like 24
hours 48 hours 72 hours and computing
those features takes a long time because
we have hundreds of millions of data
points and we're looking we're doing
like look back windows and so I think
there might be a talk floating around
the internet somewhere that my colleague
gave about like approximate counting
that we do to like speed this up using
like hyper log logs but it really still
does take like a long time to run jobs
and the other point is that sampling
doesn't really help like usually you can
just like sample down your data right
and like cool we can train a model but
the the really value of the feature is
that you're counting stuff across all of
stripe and so like you need all you know
all your data to be these features and
so because we have so many jobs that
take super long to run we use this
package called Luigi to manage all the
dependencies and Luigi's things like a
workflow manager who's written that
Spotify and and the idea is basically
you can run what this supposed to be
kind of like a dag you can run a bunch
of different jobs and like whatever the
ones that like there are some jobs that
depend on previous jobs whenever the
dependencies are done then you'll kick
off your other job if it fails you'll be
able to like gracefully restart for us
the other useful thing is that like a
bunch of these jobs you like if you want
to update if you want to add a new
feature like say a static feature you
can just rerun the static feature job
and you won't have to run run all the
like dynamic future jobs that take
forever you just rerun one job and like
join them back together but then you can
train your model so this is like an
example of what the Luigi job kind of
looks like for us so like there's this
requires function that says okay these
are the component jobs you have to run
and if we made just a change to like
static features then it would only rerun
static teachers and all the other jobs
would just like we'd use the old output
and then join together the results from
the new job and then there's like we've
written a lot of decorators we used to
use like a sequel engine called Impala
but now we use something called red
shift which is Amazon's region and so it
just like automatically loads into a
database where like all of our futures
are the inquiry abul
yeah this is kind of one of those jobs
might look like it's not actually Python
this is Scala but there's a troll face
in the corner will did you know uh
coming to a Python conference you get
some Scala um it's kind of its kind of
kind of contrived but it's like load up
all our data from related charges and
like calculate counts and then like
output them with this kind of like
mapping over like mapreduce over all
charges um okay so this is kind of an
interesting story about when I tried to
add like email features to our models it
was kind of something that definitely
should have been in the model like from
from like v 0 in fact I think we had a
user once that emailed me it was like
why am I getting all this fraud like we
could see they're all related by email
it's like any brain dead person could
tell and it's like yeah that's true but
so it was challenging about it was that
ok so we calculated all these counts
related to email and retrain the model
and so like I said these features are
kind of like okay how like what's the
velocity of charges coming from it any
given email anytime and okay so you
train random forest look at like feature
importance future importance of the
feature is high you look at like uh you
cut your cross-validation results it's
better than the old model like when you
include this feature but then deploy to
staging and I didn't really talk about
this but we have environment where
basically we do dark breeds of
production traffic so like every model
before it gets actually deployed get
scored like scores all production
traffic and then we look it over let's
say okay it's fine we should deploy it
so while we were doing that we noticed
like okay that's super weird there's a
bunch of false positives like charges
that look totally fine like would have
gotten blocked if we deployed this and
even more curiously like you'd expect
that like high velocity like a bunch of
different cards coming from the same
email that like that's kind of
I'm kind of like monotonically so like
if you have if you've seen like 50
charges coming from the same heel in
like the last minute that should be like
that should give you a higher
probability fraud right but that wasn't
the case so did some fired up ipython
the Panda is like buzzword buzzword did
some old-fashioned data analysis and
found that the likelihood of fraud was
way higher when he knows undefined
fourteen percent verse five percent was
the conditional probabilities that was
kind of weird because what that meant
was like email being missing was kicked
fraud like um I guess you can contrive
like circumstances where it would be
like a little bit predictive but not to
the tune of like you know 2x difference
right or 3x difference like in
conditional probability like that's
that's crazy so what's going on so email
is an attribute of the stripe customer
object and what happens is when you're
interacting with the stripe API you say
like you send an API request says like I
want to create a customer here's like
the details on that customer and we I
think do a really sensible thing which
is like validate the credit card
associate with that customer have the
card doesn't validate or if you get a
decline from the card network then we
say okay we can't create this customer
via Carter and don't create the customer
ah but the thing is that fraud is
correlated with declines right like we
just said card networks from their own
fraud algorithms and like decline when
when they think it's fraudulent and so
like fries correlate with declines and
so fraud is correlate with emails it's
it's because of this artifact that we
see these conditional probabilities and
so what happens is the data generating
process is okay people create customers
if there are cards get declined when
they're creating customers new a
customer exists like field is undefined
and then when we try to use this model
on live traffic we find is like
unsuspecting users regular users who
might not be sending us e-mail because
they don't collect email I like their
their app just doesn't require it like
send us charges we look at it you know
you send it through the random forest
and like roughly you say ok the
conditional probability of fraud given
that no email is on this charge is like
way higher than than before then what
then when you have you know and so it's
like ok block it until we see like crazy
false positives um and so that's a case
of I think like okay like all the
pipelines are there all the toolings
there right like the the valuations look
good but it still turned out you had to
do some like manual work to figure out
what's going on with this model and how
can we make it work so the other the
other thing okay so then the next step
is like okay well I guess is part of the
model evaluation but like after like
after you train them all you might ask a
lot of questions about like okay how do
we how do we know that it's a a model
that we should deploy right or that
samal that we should like we should
actually use this model and what we have
is a service called top model that was
written by a colleague of mine Julia
Evans and what it is it's a flat gap
it's the charts the result you like
basically you train like a classifier
and you upload the results to top model
just kind of backed by some file system
like we use s32 bakit and then what you
get out is kind of scores like
performance metrics as well as charts of
like precision recall RSC things like
that and I think it's kind of like a
cross between a lab notebook and Kaggle
so if you don't know what Kaggle is it's
this website that lets you do like
prediction competitions and I think it's
actually quite conducive to
like creating really good models because
you've got like this standard truth of
basically they cackled gives you like
okay here's like this test set and
everybody trains on the same data and
evaluates their model on the same test
set and so you have this leaderboard
that says like okay like very clearly
this is the best model this second best
model this there's a small and a given
that environment it's kind of like very
easy for people to optimize like okay
like try adding these features are like
try to tune these parameters and to top
model for us we kind of try to like
recreate the environment as much as
possible yo so the only thing to know it
is like this is open source and if you
want to try it out like please do if you
want to send PRS please do or if you
just feel like sending thoughts that
would be great too so there's a
screenshot of like what the graph would
look like for comparing a couple
different models and this is like this
is fake data but I don't know if you can
see in the corner it says like what that
with the test data set is it's like a
test data from from May to June and we
basically have three different models
that were run all on the same data set
one of them being the production model
that was trained like however many
months ago and to the other two being
like two candidate models and so like
when we look at a graph like this from
Top Model like obviously okay blue is
higher than red so like red red is the
current production model so we'd be like
okay we could use blue cool the other
thing we might look at is okay um what
like what is they like how should we
actually action this model like what
scores should we decline which scores to
be like ask for extra verification and
the way we do it is say like okay we
care about a certain level precision
like we want like essentially no false
positives just because like we see so
many transactions
um let me basically feel like okay like
right here we're like Precision's like
ninety-eight percent like and recalls
whatever you know we'll just live with
that recall like the score associated
with that data point is like where we'll
run this model and so this is kind of
what like our like training script would
look like or I guess our model
benchmarking script would look like
every single month i want to say we
would generate new benchmarks and we
benchmark all our old models that we've
trained already and then like every time
you train a new model you ask okay like
how does it compare and you could look
at the characteristics of that
performance um so yeah this code is like
pulling down the outcomes or like the
test set from Top Model turning the
model into like a sequel query because
we already have all our features loaded
into to red shift and then just like
scoring all it's like scoring this test
set then sitting back to top them all so
yeah like
that all sounds like well and good but
I'm the super annoying thing I guess if
anyways ever worked with like Python and
like pickles and like serializing like
objects out of like scikit-learn it's
just like super annoying pickles sounds
so great because like you get the native
object back right but then you can't
change any of the underlying code or
like it breaks so then we've got this
script that says okay like every time we
train a model we store the get revision
and then so when we want to load of the
pickle like first thing you do is like
check out the older vision that the
model was trained with like okay fine we
saw that problem but then like sometimes
scikit-learn changes like infrequently
but like it's happened and in fact like
I think we went from we were using like
0.14 it an upgrade to 0.16 and doing
that change they decide to add arguments
to the underlying see representation of
the tree so it's like you get this era
of like oh like seeing it takes five
positional arguments not for it's like
okay well thanks I thought I feel like
thought that would be fine like at least
psych it would be fine but like so
that's solvable too i guess which is
like okay as part of your benchmarking
script like fire up a new virtual
environment like with the old version
you're like whatever version of psych it
you trained them all on but like that
all starts to get like pretty heavy
weight for just you know restoring an
old model like our current solution is
we just like output all the they like
the actual things that you would need to
score the random forest with like the
nodes and like work like how you
traverse down the tree and like what are
the different probabilities at the
bottom but it's kind of goofy it's like
we just rewritten like the scoring code
to like to get around that
yeah so in summary i guess if we run a
little we have a whole bunch of
different tasks in this like pipeline
and python glues together everything we
use it to run like code front like
Hadoop code the Scala / loop code and
then like a bunch of different tasks
around like model valuation like like
even just like just manually
introspecting models and adding like a
simple feature it turned out to be can
be surprisingly hard if you like you
don't know about the process that
generates the data before I worked at
stripe I was a consultant and it was
like just a nightmare always trying to
figure out like what what even is the
data that you're sending us at stripe it
slightly easier because you can go poke
around the source code but even then you
need to know like what exactly is going
on and the last thing is that like yeah
we spend a ton of time doing like
feature engineering and my evaluation at
least with apply machine learning I
think like it's not about like slinging
algorithms right like trying out neural
networks and like knit you know like gb
tees and like whatever like that's
that's we just like pick something
simple and roll with it and then like
there's a lot to be gained from just
getting the pipeline right yeah so
that's all I had prepared anybody has
any questions
hello hi thanks for the talk I'm
presumably so I work at go cordless so
you know where payment service provider
as well and presumably the ratio of for
certain on Foster is really low how did
you get around that class imbalance did
you use we start playing did you how did
you in between fraudsters and down for
us yeah exactly um we don't really do
anything special there I mean like I
think the main thing is that we have
that composite outcome like we go we we
try to like find all the fraud that we
can and like boost the model like we do
have some work that's been done around
like okay because like fraud tags aren't
totally known like fraud is a sensor
calm right like you will not find out
you will not get the fraud tag for every
single charge that's fraudulent like we
first pre process where we run like like
label imputation algorithms to be like
okay given like this set of initial tags
like like retag a bunch of charges and
then used as like kind of artificial
tags to then train our models um it's
the answer your question hey there is
the fraud that you already known you can
model it etc there is the type of fraud
that you've never seen before do you
have any approaches of finding this kind
of fraud um I mean I think the main
thing is that uh like the models are way
more generalizable then like I mean if
that's like the most general thing that
we can do is like you find patterns like
okay if there's a ton of charges coming
from this email that I'm like that is
like indicative of fraud and like yeah
sure like fraud sir you can like change
up the way that they change their you
know whatever they're sending like
charged over they can change it out but
like usually there is some something
identifying it that we've seen before
I mean as far as like not being a like
not having seen like the pattern at all
like yeah yeah we can't really see the
future right so we just have to like
retrain the model and so like I guess
the hard part is just making that whole
pipeline as quick as possible so that
you see something new and you just like
hit a button retrain like you know go
through the whole process and then
retrain the model but like otherwise
yeah I think that's the best you can do
yeah so the question was because we've
had problems with pickles like had we
ever tried p FML um we looked at it
briefly but like a lot of our
serialization code was written before
like that was really kind of
standardized or like a thing I think um
and we really are like uh the thing i
didn't mention is like we do a lot of
monitoring and psych it but we've also
like written a bunch of code to like
train models to train distributed trees
like on hadoop and so it's kind of just
easier to use the format that you know
we've kind of created in-house from a
from a business perspective have you
considered are false positives or false
negatives more significant for you from
a reputational point of view and if so
is that something you're taking into
account with the with the modeling so i
can really hear the question is ready
with the with when building your models
you find that false positives or false
negatives are more significant other
sort of business point of view not only
taken into account and yeah models um I
think like a cross stripe like false
positives are definitely the thing that
we most care about minimizing because
like if we deploy a model like I said
when we deploy a model for all of stripe
like the precision require
there are like super high like we're
shooting for like ninety-eight
ninety-nine percent precision for any
given user that like has a fraud problem
like we have the ability to train models
that are like specific to a user and
that like or I mean it's not even just
about training model right it's like all
so you can like tweak the the threshold
at which you action the scores but yeah
for the point is like for any given
merchant like that that has like high
fraud we might like dial it up or down
to focus more on like false negatives
yeah yeah so I guess that doesn't really
depends obviously business questions
baby i'm just a new thing to see because
I we know I looking at I mean earlier on
we're looking at similar sort of all I
know he's gonna be a problem time we'd
have to think about so I'm just you know
just wondering what you you've found
that result
that's a doctor I guess the microphones
gonna do you have access to more social
information about the customers than the
email address like addresses or
telephone numbers were anything like
that um sometimes we do it doesn't
really come through this stripe avi
directly so like the main things that we
look at are the things that come like
through like the native stripe objects
and then there are various ways in which
you can send through like metadata on
the charge but then like those are kind
of specific to any tenant given user and
so like like I was saying the value like
our most valuable features are things
that look across all of stripe and you
we don't really get that with like the
features that aren't like required set
we're not required but you know like
everybody uses them um we have been
thinking about how to like set up I mean
just like a fraud API general fraud API
where you like send sends do everything
but like right now it's just people sent
through on the metadata and then we use
it and because it's kind of limited it's
like limited use we we do use it a lot
for the other version of fraud that I
didn't talk about which is like figuring
out our people trying to defraud us like
have they signed up for fake stripe
accounts and so will like sometimes
require like Twitter github or you know
whatever and make use of that but for a
transaction fraud not so much I used to
work in fraud detection and we had quite
a lot of success doing kind of to
network steps away yeah like this email
address has been used in by a customer
who used this address and this address
has been linked with a lot of fraud all
right but the problem with that is then
it's very difficult to train your model
because if you have some fraud outcomes
that you know but they come from a time
after certain links in the network
happen then you can't use those links
the network yeah a different time with
the outcome I was wondering if you
covered it but it sounds like you don't
really do that for that bit of the
training yeah I mean well that's like a
general problem of like ex post
information right like
is it yeah cool thank you that cool
thanks just a sort of general question
any views on things like Apple pay and
use of biometrics is that gonna kind of
kill off some fraud sort of threats or
what's your sort of views on that yeah
uh one would hope right but like somehow
you know I don't know about alpha pay
specifically like their fraud their
anti-fraud metrics are like how well
they do but I did read an article unlike
the new york times about how like there
was quite a bit of fraud related to like
because i think it was email
verification and the original thing that
they did with email verification and
because like Apple accounts are so
valuable like all of a sudden there's
like this trafficking and like you know
validated Apple accounts so like my
senses or at least my approach is that
like we just assume that any given
credential can be compromised like you
can you can throw on more and more
layers of validation but like you know
they'll just like the market will
respond like there will be cards that
have the correct CBC in the correct pin
and like all that they'll just cost a
little bit more um and so in that sense
like uh I guess like hopefully there is
like some perfect encryption scheme and
then like we won't have jobs anymore but
like until then we're kind of just like
grasping at straws right tried to text
it yeah yeah the question is can we go
on the darknet and harvest cardless and
I think we could but then it comes back
to you like that's not super scalable
right unless we like we could write
scrapers that scrape these forums but
then like I'm sure they would they would
respond and so then you know we could
like start a new division of strife
fraud anti-fraud where it's like okay
harvest like card numbers but so far
like the more effective thing has been
like fine characters
cool well I think those bids me all the
time I out anyway so yeah thanks